ya lo decíamos continuamos con directo a
este jueves el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden extendió el decreto de
emergencia por la situación que se vive
en Nicaragua y advirtió que esta crisis
sigue siendo una amenaza para Estados
Unidos para ampliar este tema conectamos
con Andrés Suárez Jaramillo les
corresponsal para Centroamérica de
France 24 Andrés de qué se trata este
decreto de emergencia sobre Nicaragua y
en qué se basan para extenderlo
el decreto de emergencia sobre Nicaragua
lo firmó inicialmente Donald Trump en
noviembre de 2018 recordemos ese año
crítico en el cual Nicaragua atravesó
una crisis que dejó más de 300 civiles
muertos ese decreto perdería toda su
vigencia el 27 de noviembre de este año
de manera que Joe biden decidió
prorrogarlo Un año más y así lo estipuló
en la carta que le presentó ayer jueves
al congreso
denotando varios puntos muy importantes
uno de ellos como se puede leer y es que
el régimen de Ortega y Murillo está
socavando la democracia y el estado de
derecho de Nicaragua Así mismo los
responsabilizó de ejecutar violencia y
discriminada y tácticas represora en
contra de los civiles Y por último los
culpabilizó de ser actores corruptos una
conducta por la cual se estaría
desestabilizando la economía de los
nicaragüenses este decreto de emergencia
Nacional de Estados Unidos sobre
Nicaragua en la práctica lo que es es
bloquear todas aquellas propiedades de
los nicaragüenses de ciertas personas
que viven en Estados Unidos y que se
estarían contribuyendo a esta situación
en Nicaragua además de retirarles la
visa y la permanencia en este país en el
cual han decidido pues tener todo su
dinero pero otro punto muy interesante
según los expertos de este decreto
nacional es el hecho de que Nicaragua
estaría siendo un país
amenazando inusualmente la seguridad
Nacional de los Estados Unidos todo por
cuenta del contexto de la Guerra de
Ucrania desde julio de este año cuando
decidió recibir armas rusas todo el
armamento y las tropas rusas en esta
región centroamericana bueno y tras los
comicios del domingo qué apoyos y
críticas ha recibido el mandatario de
sus pares latinoamericanos
los países que siempre lo apoyan en
América Latina son Venezuela y Cuba hoy
se pudo ver por ejemplo el apoyo de el
presidente venezolano Nicolás Maduro
también el de Miguel Díaz canel
felicitándolo hoy por su cumpleaños
número 77 pero también por ese resultado
ganador del 100% de los comicios
municipales Pero no por ser de izquierda
otros presidentes en cambio se han
manifestado en contra uno de ellos con
mayor vehemencia ha sido Gabriel borich
desde chile quien condenó los resultados
de esos comicios que de 153 alcaldías en
disputa el sandinismo se quedó con la
153 alcaldías Por lo cual dijo que chile
siempre estará presto a contribuir para
restablecer el estado de derecho y la
democracia en este país
centroamericano y finalmente pues
Gustavo Petro en un foro internacional
en Francia al preguntársele por su
relación con Nicaragua recordemos
Gustavo el primer presidente de
izquierda de Colombia lo que dijo fue
que Nicaragua se encuentra en litigio
con Colombia y que sería Nicaragua quien
le está robando le está quitando el mar
a los colombianos